[Musique]
les poudres salés comme celui-ci sont
populaires dans la réfrigérateurs mais
peu de gens savent quoi en faire
très curieux de découvrir la recette du
succès des herbes salées du bas du
fleuve nous sommes allés faire un tour à
Sainte-Flavie
[Musique]
bonjour
c'est ici que la conquête de nos frigo a
commencé comment vous avez fait pour
être dans tous les frigos du Québec à
peu près il y a un secret de marketing
là-dedans le produit a fait de sa place
et aussi moi j'ai aussi eu beaucoup de
patience pour être capable d'être
heureux le produit les obsolets c'est
véritablement une recette traditionnelle
allemande ici au Québec on l'avait pas
été quand même une façon de le faire et
on prenait les résidus du jardin des
excédents de légumes des choses comme ça
qu'on achète un salé à peu près
n'importe comment on utilise ça pour
faire notre cuisine les herbes salées
existent depuis aussi longtemps qu'on
salles les viandes et les poissons mais
l'entreprise de Sainte-Flavie a été
créée en 1965
ma mère a converti la ferme en ferme
maraîchère et commencer à transformer
certains produits donc à l'origine ma
mère passait des nuits à hacher finement
les choses pour pouvoir aller céleri
carottes persil poireaux ciboulette
sarriette et cerfeuil ce sont les
ingrédients principaux qui donnent toute
sa saveur aux condiments un peu
d'épinards
au niveau des herbes qui vont donner
finalement une saveur puis le
balancement c'est le cercueil et la
serviette à l'intérieur du produit qui
lui mélanger avec les autres donne
finalement cette puissance de goût et
qui reste dans l'animal il y a que deux
ingrédients que nous produisons pas à la
ferme c'est le céleri et une partie de
l'Union et acheter à l'extérieur
en groupe la partie ici
mais le feuillage est consommé aussi
pour le verre
si ça c'est du persil oui alors
ça se passe c'est là que ça se passe
tout est récolter à la main tout est
lavé transformé à la main la seule
mécanisation c'est le hachoir qui est
fait mécaniquement chaque ingrédient est
préparé salé et entreposer séparément en
Barry en fait le sel c'est vraiment
l'agent de conservation quels
pour permettre que le produit demeure et
que sa couleur
les ingrédients sont mélangés au moment
de l'emballage par une petite équipe le
nombre d'employés double au moment de la
récolte pour produire annuellement
environ 400 000 pots on transforme les
produits principalement en été on
emballe toute l'année
conservent trois ans sur le comptoir ou
une fois ouvert trois ans au
réfrigérateur
composé de 80% de végétaux et 20% de sel
le condimage ou le rôle de rehausseur de
goût à quantité égale les heures salées
sont moins saliques le sel de table je
vous dirais que c'est épaulement une des
meilleures façons de réduire le sel dans
les aliments
nous avons apporté des herbes salées au
chef Kim côté du restaurant Côté est à
Kamouraska on vous a apporté des herbes
salées faites à Sainte-Flavie le petit
pot en plastique que tout le monde est
dans son frigo bah oui les herbes salées
c'est le fun moi j'utilise beaucoup dans
les soupes mais pommes de terre pilées
puissante poisson elle étouffée puis
aussi des hommes qui sont naturels
aussi il y en a d'autres arts la seule
cornectique qui pousse sur le bord du
fleuve qui sont salés naturellement et
puis en plus c'est vraiment un produit
d'ici que ça fait partie de notre
patrimoine culinaire le persil maire
qu'est-ce qui est particulier c'est ça
goûte vraiment le persil mais le petit
côté salin qui est le fun qui va se
démarquer du persil italien il est un
peu plus ferme aussi avec un autre
texture qui est qui est propre à lui
puis propre à ici on peut mettre ça
n'importe où quand même là
inspiré par les herbes du bas du fleuve
que nous nous avons apporté qui nous a
préparé un repas composé entièrement de
produits locaux une soupe aux légumes
avec haricots et pintade de la région
purée de pommes de terre on va mettre
les armes salées puis du beurre non moi
je mets beaucoup de beurre et qu'on en
profite pendant que c'est chaud
[Musique]
et comme plat de résistance un filet de
morue fraîche en papillote
je mets mes arbres salées à Claudie les
jardins de la mer
en plus de s'approvisionner dans son
propre jardin le chef se procure aussi
les herbes salées cueillies sur les
battures à quelques kilomètres de son
restaurant Au Jardin de la mer plante
marine Persée de mer plantain maritime
salicorne algue celle de mer oignons
poireaux et carottes
un vrai repas en plein air dans le
Kamouraska avec Kim côté on peut mettre
au lieu de mettre du sel on met les
hommes salés puis on en met deux trois
bonnes cuillères à soupe pour
du sel non plus
le plus avec le poisson c'est plus léger
c'est plus subtil c'est plus
complémentaire peut-être mais bravo
c'est délicieux merci
[Musique]